tu aurais posé une question générale
mais qui part du cas particulier de
raquel garrido
oui à quelle garrido elle me fait de
plus plus en plus penser à la chauve
souris de la fontaine s'il ya une fable
de la fontaine où la chauve souris quand
ça l'arrangé le dit mais je suis un
oiseau gdl et puis quand ça l'arrangé
bien non je suis pas un oiseau parce que
j'ai pas de plumes skis le cas de raquel
garrido je ne peut l'étendre à toute la
france insoumise
c'est qui a tout en un double jeu un
double discours
lorsque vous prenez est ce que vous êtes
alors d'ailleurs tu l'as fait le numéro
il ya trois minutes il n'y a pas cette
démocratie la vème république ce n'est
pas assez démocratique il faut passer à
la 6ème d'ailleurs si c'est votre
chiffre fétiche cinéma public 6 % aux
élections heureusement voulais pas
repartir à la 4è sinon ce sera encore
6,3 d'or moi j'ai lu le livre d'un
ancien de la france un smith thomas
guénolé la chute de la maison mélenchon
qui nous explique que le lieu le moins
démocratique de france c'est la france
est soumise la france a soumises et
dirigé à peu près de la même manière que
la roumanie alors une liste n'est pas
dirigée par les époux ceausescu par jean
luc mélenchon puisque nous venons à lui
et sofia chico c'est à dire que personne
en plus qu'ils sont unis par des liens
assez trouble liens personnels liens
d'affaires d'adp est à la fois
responsable de la france insoumise et
puis prestataires de services enfin la
justice fera le tri dans tout ça c'est
pas bon c'est pas mon proc et mais
simplement dans le désamour envers jean
luc mélenchon et envers la france
insoumise d'où la chute pour l'un et
pour l'autre est vertigineuse
il y à cette impression qui plus qu'une
impression qui pour moi une certitude
c'est que vous êtes des hypocrites des
maîtres du double jeu vous voulez la
démocratie pour tout le monde sauf au
sein de la france a soumises et le livre
de thomas guénolé et ravageur parce
qu'il va dans le détail c'est quelqu'un
qui parle de l'intérieur parce qu'il a
vu au jour le jour que toutes les bonnes
paroles que vous réservé aux médias et
bien vous vous en abstenir
pour vous quel est votre question est
basse et ça je ne peux qu ils
reconnaissent dans la démocratie c'est
pas une question avec naulleau manor
poser une question mais c'est la
question pourquoi ne pas mettre en
accord
le fonctionnement la france a soumis
savez ce que vous prenez pour le
fonctionnement de la france
je peux pas faire plus simple la gorge
c'est alors tout ça s'est appuyé sur un
livre le pauvre thomas guénolé qui de
quelqu'un que j'ai bien connu il
habitait montreuil et j'étais plutôt
amené avec lui mais il a été très déçu
parce que sur le choix de la liste
électorale européenne n'était pas placée
haut niveau
il fallait d'accord il voulait être en
position éligible il était chroniqueur
avant et puis il a trouvé que dans le
système de désignation interne des corps
la place ne lui convenait pas après il a
cherché à être en position pour être à
la mairie de montreuil tu vois je suis
député de montreuil et puis au niveau
des militants ça passait pas et pas prêt
il a eu une affaire parce que une
étudiante vu qu'il raconte dans ce
bouquin je vais dire qu'il a eu à
déconsidérer qu'il a fait du harcèlement
sexuel
et il ya eu nous on était gêné au niveau
de la france socialiste moi j'ai appris
après coup c'est que ce soit tu fais
rien et mediapart est en train de
préparer un article
et tu te fais taper en disant vous fait
rien alors qu'une jeune femme à la
france ensuite
soit il ya eu une commission d'écouté
qui peut-être a été malmené c'est pas ma
question n'avait compris mais c'est
logique c'est que c'est l'inversé je ne
sais que c'est pas un personnage neutre
c'est quelqu'un qui directement quitte
la france en suisse alors que la veille
si j'ai le temps je te montrer les sms
me alexis tu es formidable pourrait
faire ceci et d'un seul coup ça et il
explique qu'en fait il vivait en corée
du nord
il a franchi le mur maintenance et la
corée du sud il vient de passer six mois
dans une dictature
si j'étais franchement cyril vous
pourrez repasser tous les moments de
lèche cul de mélenchon de guénolé à la
télé oui trouvé ça formidable et du jour
au lendemain c'est le goulag
ces crédits eric naulleau mois dix
points que vous dire je sais c'est nul
je vais me faire l'avocat de la rime à
rien avec 6 corbières et les becs qui
écrivent ensuite un livre pour cracher
dans la soupe fois je promets je prends
les choses vraiment avec des pensées
jouer surtout que je vais te dire et et
disent attachés édition apporte qui va
pas écrire un bouquin d'édition non mais
vous connaissez le business
il a fait tourner de médias on n'a
jamais vu ça tous les médias il a vendu
6 124 livre pour dire l'intérêt que son
nouveau à trouver pas encore tous les
médias numériques c'était un besner mais
parce que c'est une grosse connerie qui
n'a d'argent et bien quelques naulleau
en france qui disent je pensais que
c'était un dictateur il ya mais qui
il ya deux ans mais n'a pas de réponse a
dit la vérité
on voit un mec qui écrit un livre après
avoir été des années des années à la
france a soumis et qui crache dans la
soupe derrière c'est bien sûr la voix et
sa parole pour calculer ce que vous avez
à l'injure en chroniqueur donne allez
vous fâcher avec toutes mes affaires en
bouquet attendent là c'est un pourri à
cela on va dire la preuve comme ça pour
rien c'est dans cette chronique il
s'agit pas les barrages et dans la soupe
mais si à celle de nonce a filmé
crédibilise pas ce qu'ils racontent ils
racines qu'est ce que vous en servez la
démocratie ça mais moi j'ai lu le
bouquin est alors bouclée pour voilà
pourquoi vous croyez le bouquin moi j'ai
menti je me crée un bouquin demain à
celui ci très étayé ses traits et il
explique que la démocratie ça a révélé
par mean et l'oeuf avec son regard
savait qu'on allait enfin oui mais
attendez un web demain russies alexis
corbière
il peut créer un livre très bien sûr les
arcanes de la france a soumis on va dire
de série no ya un aspect intéressant un
bouquin de saut thomas guénolé je veux
pas faire la pub c'est la fin où il dit
qu'en fait qu'il est en désaccord avec
la stratégie de la fondation louise ça
c'est intéressant je ne savais pas le
quand il était à l'inter mais ça c'est
intéressant tout le reste je vais vous
dire vous l'avez lu c'est quoi ces on
recolle les morceaux de ce qui est écrit
ailleurs et c'est expliquer pour quelles
raisons effectivement ils n'étaient pas
plus haut sur la liste européenne en
position éligible paske évidence une
dictature il était en 14e place et la
réalité dans les six premiers de la
trouvais ça formidable